-Good evening, everyone.
What a great crowd
we have tonight.
I'm thrilled.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study,
and I am so pleased to welcome
you all here tonight for Plays
With Words.
This night of comedy opens our
conference, Ways With Words,
exploring language and gender,
which will continue here
at the Knafel Center tomorrow.
Every year, the
Radcliffe Institute
hosts a conference to
examine a timely issue
through the lens of gender.
In so doing, we
affirm our connection
to the stark mission
of Radcliffe College,
but we also host a
gender conference
because the interdisciplinary
environment of our Institute
for Advanced Study is
precisely the right place
to grapple with the multiple
dimensions of gender
in society.
Where else would you
find performers, poets,
computer scientists,
transgender rights advocates,
political scientists, and
more, deep in conversation?
No such effort comes
together all on its own.
So I am grateful to John
Huth, our conference chair,
co-director of our science
program here at the Radcliffe
Institute, and Donner
Professor of Science
in the Faculty of Arts and
Sciences here at Harvard.
Thank you also to everyone
at the Radcliffe Institute.
And believe me, it took
everyone, especially
Rebecca Wasserman
and her staff, who
worked so hard to organize
this ambitious event.
In recent years, our
gender conferences
have explored a wide array
of prominent public issues,
migration, public health, and
violence, just to name a few.
And all of our
gender conferences
have begun with an arts event.
We choose art as
our first encounter
with critical social, political,
and cultural topics for reasons
that go beyond the aesthetic.
Art demands that we approach
a subject in a new way,
and we see it differently
than we did before.
One year, a dramatic
reading by Eve Ensler
propelled our inquiry into
gender and the public's health.
At a conference
on immigration, we
launched it with a
musical performance
by Quetzal, a bilingual rock
band from east Los Angeles.
This year, we open
with performances
by Aparna Nancherla
and ImprovBoston.
I want to thank them all,
as well as Professor Glenda
Carpio, and local WBUR
radio host Robin Young,
who will be leading
our discussion.
More arts programming
accompanies this conference,
and it surrounds us here
at Radcliffe in general.
And I urge you to
visit, in particular,
an exhibit that has just gone
up, "A Language to Hear Myself"
Feminist Poets Speak, which is
next door at the Schlesinger
Library, and it will be
open throughout the spring.
One week from tonight, just
to mention one more event,
on Thursday, March
10th, Luci Tapahonso,
who is the poet laureate
of the Navajo Nation,
will be giving a poetry reading.
The calendar cards on your seats
will list more upcoming events,
and I hope you will join
us for many of them.
Tonight's evening of comedy has
brought students and faculty,
artists and alumni,
social workers and CEOs,
electrical engineers, medical
practitioners, activists,
and more, together here
in the Knafel Center.
You represent nine
different Harvard schools,
nearly two dozen local
universities, and several area
public schools.
You have come from
all over New England,
and as far afield as the
University of Notre Dame
and the National
Theater of Canada.
I know that others are watching
our live webcast tonight,
and that many more will watch
the video on our website
in the months and years to come.
The breadth and
diversity of our audience
tells us something about
the genre of comedy.
The urge to laugh is universal.
Humor can soothe
tensions, cross divides,
and unite people through the
medium of shared laughter.
But paradoxically,
what makes people laugh
is not universal at all.
A joke that is funny in one
time, place, or culture,
does not automatically translate
across time, space, or context.
And while the action of laughing
can bring people together,
the content of jokes can
sometimes drive people apart,
or divide them into groups
of ridiculers and ridiculed.
Comedy then might make
us feel light hearted,
but it is no
intellectual lightweight.
It does important social
and cultural work,
and activists of
all kinds know that.
In 2014, for example,
transgender advocates
petitioned Jon Stewart
and Stephen Colbert to,
and I quote from their demands,
"reject transphobia and respect
gender identity."
The petitioners wanted support
from Stewart and Colbert
on transgender
rights because they
knew that the popularity of
The Daily Show and The Colbert
Report had contributed, in the
words of their petition, to,
and I quote, "the
recent cultural shift
toward support for equal
rights for LGBT people."
In other words activists
sought to recruit
two popular humorists precisely
because they understood
how much comedy matters.
One reason why comedy
matters is that it tells us
a lot about the
state of language.
Jokes are only funny
if you understand them.
Frequently, understanding
jokes requires understanding
the words used to tell them.
But words are not stable.
Their meanings change over time.
New words come into existence,
and then they fade away.
Ideas about gender
change over time too.
The social roles
assigned to individuals
on the basis of
sex and assumptions
about relationships
among and between sexes
are in constant flux.
They also vary widely from
place to place and culture
to culture.
So comedy can reveal a lot
about sex, gender, and sexuality
in a particular
historical moment.
It reveals even more
about how we use language
to discuss challenging issues.
So let me give you
three examples.
We know that William
Shakespeare played to the pit,
so even the most serious history
plays or catastrophic tragedies
were peppered with jokes that
would be funny to cheap seat
audiences.
Take Henry the
Fourth, where scenes
featured the portly
knight Falstaff
and the barmaid
Mistress Quickly.
Today, the humor
in their dialogue
is not immediately apparent,
unless we have an Elizabethan
dictionary by our side.
When Falstaff says to
Mistress Quickly, and I quote,
"there is no more faith in
thee than in a stewed prune,"
the phrase stewed prune sounds
mildly entertaining to us,
but we don't split
our sides laughing.
In contrast, 16th
century audiences
did laugh uproariously,
because they, unlike us, all
knew that Falstaff had just
called Quickly as faithful
as a prostitute.
Here's another example.
In the spring of
1865, a comedy called
Our American Cousins was playing
at Ford's Theater in Washington
DC.
That play contained a line, "you
sockdologizing old mantrap."
That line doesn't mean
very much to us today,
but John Wilkes Booth was
an accomplished actor who
knew that script
inside and out, and he
knew that that line
would get the most
laughs in the entire play.
He shot Abraham Lincoln
at that exact moment, when
that line was delivered, because
he assumed the audience would
laugh so hard that nobody
would hear the gunshot,
and he would have
precious time to get away.
It turned out he was right.
A more contemporary
example comes
from Seinfeld, the hit
television comedy of the 1990s.
In one episode,
Elaine agrees to pose
as the girlfriend of a gay
man who has a homophobic boss.
After a pleasant
evening at the opera,
Elaine decides that she
will convert the man, that's
her language, and she asks
him if he ever considered
what she calls changing teams.
Now that we know about
the pernicious phenomenon
of subjecting boys to abuse
of so-called conversion
camps in efforts to cure
them of their sexuality,
we in 2016 have a very
difficult time hearing
that line as light or funny.
This last example is recent
enough for many of us
in this room to remember,
which reminds us
that there's evolution
of both language
and gender happens constantly.
It is happening now.
What is funny today may
not be so amusing tomorrow.
Noticing when we laugh
and when we don't can
provide valuable insight
into the state of language
and gender at this
precise moment
in time, which is the
subject of our gender
conference this year.
I said at the beginning
of these remarks
that the purpose of
our gender conference
is to look at an important
topic through a lens of gender.
To return to that
metaphor, comedy
calibrates the
prescription for that lens
with exquisite delicacy.
By looking through it,
we can see our own moment
in our own cultural context
with heightened clarity.
I can think of nobody more
qualified to help us do so
than the talented performers
and insightful commentators
we have with us this evening.
Your program contains
informative biographies
about all of them,
and I encourage
you to take a good look at it.
So here is how the
evening will proceed.
First, Aparna will treat us
to a stand up performance.
Next Robin Young, co-host
of WBUR's Here and Now
will moderate a discussion
between Aparna and Glenda
Carpio, professor of English
and African and African-American
studies here at Harvard.
Then we will enjoy a performance
by the improvisational comedy
group ImprovBoston.
After their performance,
ImprovBoston members
will join in the conversation
with Aparna and Glenda.
And finally, the floor will be
open to you for your questions.
If you would like
to ask a question,
please form a line behind
the microphone that
will be put in the center
aisle, identify yourself,
and ask your question.
In closing, let me just say
that I hope to see you all back
here tomorrow for
a day of continued
discussion at our Ways
of Words conference.
So please join me in
welcoming Aparna Nancherla.
-Hello, thank you for having me.
What a warm up.
Give it up for you're-- I know.
Well I want to jump
right into things.
I feel like we don't have a
lot of time left here on earth.
Things are ending, so it's
good to get to the point.
Well, I know this is
an academic conference,
and usually I perform
in bars and various also
classy locations,
but I wanted to,
in the spirit of the
conference, put together
my version of a lecture
of just my experiences
with comedy and language.
So I'll just jump right into it.
OK, here it is.
You Had Me At YOLO, and
it is a big exploration
of how language exists in
an ever evolving landscape.
And of course this title
I just got through a Ted
talk random title generator.
But I thought it
sounded pretty official.
And you know, for
laypeople, is basically
pondering as on why does
that detective emoji only
come in one skin tone,
but the blond man in emoji
comes in all of them?
And of course, that
begs for pictures.
So there you go there.
There he is in all of his
depth and then versus why?
Unfortunately, I wasn't able to
get an answer to this question,
but it does seem
like you would need
like a multicultural
sleuth on the case.
And unfortunately, all we
have is a boy band to help us.
So just a disclaimer right off
the top, because I can't get
sued again.
I just don't have the time.
I have many naps to take.
So I just want to
cover all my bases.
I know this is a
conference on language,
but I just wanted to say I
cannot speak highly enough
of images.
I'm a big image
fiend, and I wanted
it to not take any power away
from images before delving
into language.
Here is just a photo that
I love that I've taken
in New York City, where I live.
This is one of my
favorite photos,
because it kind of
symbolizes everyone's attempt
to just make it work.
We're all kind of
doing the best we can.
I think that.
And of course, I don't
want to take anything away
from Kimojis, which are the
newest type of emoji that's
out, which is a way to
express your feelings
through our Supreme
leader Kim Kardashian.
And there's really
something for everyone.
You can blow gum or, see
no evil, or even graduate.
I feel like that one is a
little bit sarcastic, honestly.
I don't know when you
would ever use that.
And then lastly, of
course, foremost keepers
of words and
language are authors,
and even an author can't
resist a nice headshot.
The author photo is
something that you can never
take away from them.
This man seems to be
floating in space,
and this woman is
coming out of a tree.
So I just wanted
to cover my bases.
And then of course, I know,
language is playing with words
and very much about
words, but I know
there are a lot of people who
are into numbers and hard data,
and I just want to make
sure to give you guys
something to rest your
eyes on for a second.
So there's just some
figures for you.
This is just a light smattering
of research that I did.
So, yeah, so now let's
get into the real stuff.
So who am I?
Like language as
a whole, I think
you can say that
language is very much
informed by who is speaking it.
Like, the identity of
the speaker is big.
So a little bit about me
and some of the lenses
that I come from.
I'm a comedian.
I'm a daughter.
I'm a sister.
I'm a friend.
This is pretty much going to
read like a really long Twitter
bio.
I'm an anxious depressive.
I'm an introvert.
I'm a feminist.
I'm a heterosexual.
I'm a cis woman.
I'm a person of color.
And I gently-floating fuzzball.
That one is for tax purposes.
And then I'm a florfp.
I recently started
identifying as a florfp.
I don't know what it is,
by definitely I am one,
so that's part of
my identity now.
So we live in a very
exciting time for language.
I feel like the internet
has really opened up
the gates in terms of
just allowing people
access to a variety of things.
For example, you can just
slap a caption on a photo,
and just give an animal
a rich inner life
that it didn't have before.
Yeah that one's
pretty undeniable.
It's doing the work for me.
But even just in interacting
with people, like Facebook
recently came out with
a new set of reactions.
So instead of just liking
things, you can also love,
ha ha, yay, wow, sad, angry.
Which incidentally, this is
also kind of a life cycle of me
on Facebook.
Like at the top of
my news feed versus
how I'm feeling by the end.
But it's interesting,
after this came out,
I made a tweet
joke that was this,
"why is there no Facebook
reaction for razbliuto,
the Russian word meaning
the hollow feeling
for someone you used to love
but no longer do," which I think
applies to a lot of the
posts I check on Facebook.
And then I learned, after
posting that, that razbliuto is
not a Russian word at all.
It was somehow
incorrectly appropriated
to the Russian
language, and then
spread so quickly on the
internet that is has now
become a word in its own right
that is attributed to English,
but it has fake Russian roots.
And I guess we've
all been there.
We've all claimed to be Russian.
So I understand, but it
was a funny little study
in how quickly
language can change.
And of course language
is the key to accessing
lots of things, like in
the most literal sense,
a Wi-Fi password gives you
access to the internet.
Captcha is a word that proves
that you're not a robot.
So these are literal
uses of language.
But then I want to spend the
next part of the presentation
just talking about how language
and communicating with me
and technology has sort of
fallen into place recently
in my life.
Does anyone, let me just poll
the audience really quick,
does anyone text with their
parents and or children?
Does anyone?
Oh, very polite.
OK, great.
So you all will know
that I texted my mother,
and it's not always easy.
It can be challenging.
Usually people don't even
cheer when you ask them.
Like if they text
with their parents
they're just like,
please respect my privacy
during this difficult time.
But I've been
texting with my mom,
and I feel like she went through
a journey of learning to text.
Like this was one
of her first texts.
It was pretty much
like an email.
Like she would put my
name in the subject,
and then and then
she'd put the message.
And this one was at
the very beginning.
"hope Nashville was fun, when
we got married dad would,"
and that's it.
We never learned
what dad would do.
We never got closure
on this message.
But then she got a
little bit better,
and she started using it as
kind of a tracking device.
Like this is when we were, I
believe, in the MOMA together.
She was like, "are
you on level 4?"
And then I tried to tell her
where I was, and then she
said, "already on ground
floor and hungry please,"
which really feels
like a metaphor
for the struggle in general.
And then, lastly, she
just put my sister
and I on the same text
chain and was like,
this is just what
you're going to get.
"I did what you guys suggested.
For the first time in my life
I went to a movie by myself.
Gone Girl is a powerful movie.
I liked it."
So she's just basically
blogging in a very tight circle.
I'm really proud of her.
But then she did
get very advanced.
She started sending photos.
Like one day she just sent
the moon for some reason.
I guess she just clicked
in her lunar cycle finally,
"bigger and brighter
moon today lovelies."
That was it.
That was the whole.
That's all she wanted to say.
And then she actually reached
an end point recently,
a few months ago, where
she just sent this,
"texts are not satisfying,"
which essentially just feels
like she broke up with me.
So it feels like she really
had a whole eat, pray, love
adventure on her phone.
And then meanwhile to
compare her to my dad,
this is the range
of my dad's texts.
This is a classic.
That one's a good one.
It's either that, or it's just
very pointed questions that
don't-- really, you don't know
what they're in reference to.
But you know that it demands
an answer immediately.
So family, that's kind of
communicating with my family.
And then I was like,
OK, well what else?
Love, people are
looking for love.
Is anyone currently
online looking for love?
OK it's fine.
No one ever cheers for that.
I have to find the right noise.
I have to be like, if you're
on there make a quiet hiss.
I don't know what the noise is.
I haven't found it yet.
But I'm on all the sites.
I'm on OkCupid.
I'm on Tinder.
I spent a few weeks on Yelp.
I just wanted to
go through a couple
of the messages I've
gotten, because I
feel like I stopped responding.
And it got to a point where
I'm like, well these man,
they're putting
themselves out there,
and if they don't
have a voice here,
then where are they going to
find that in society, you know?
So I just put together sort of
an in memoriam montage of those
we have lost in the past year.
This one's a classic.
"Hello dear lady.
You're appealing beauty, cute,
sober, and captivating face
has forced me to send
a message to you.
Can we tread on the path
of friendship together?
I like you much."
So this is clearly a robot
who somehow got an account.
I don't know what happened.
But it doesn't
really improve even
when you know they're
human, like this one.
"There, how are you?"
It's clearly a cut
and paste gone wrong.
There, what happened to hi?
Someone else got that one.
"There, how are you.
I enjoyed reading your profile.
I feel we have few
things in common."
Oh, then I think we're
pretty much done,
with the few things
that we have in common.
This one is a profile of
a man who messaged me.
"I'm a man looking for
more than most men are,
which is someone
who wants the same,
but wants to have
fun getting there,"
which is basically just a
riddle from a bridge troll.
None of that makes sense.
And then he writes "I
am a work alcoholic."
I think a work alcoholic
is just a comedian,
it's just a fancy way to say it.
This one is to the point.
"Come smoke weed."
But it's more when it was
sent, which is on Christmas.
Again, it's like men communicate
differently, you know?
Clearly that was his
gift for that year.
And then this man, not
a man of many words.
He sent a frowny face.
But then, like a gentleman,
followed up three months later
with, "we should
definitely talk."
He felt like he got
off on the wrong foot
with the frowny face
three months ago.
"I can teach you how to golf."
And then this man and just
straight up wrote a poem.
We don't have to read it.
There's no time.
But basically, the
gist is that love
is like a sword fight between
your heart and these eyes.
So men clearly
communicate differently.
I hope you garnered
some of that distinction
through some of those messages.
And if you're not online,
please get on there.
You're missing out.
Another thing that happens
a lot as a comedian
is you get a lot of
internet comments.
Mine pretty much
range from hate,
which is like this one, "what
it is your problem," which
was really in
reference to nothing,
to just mild confusion
of you entirely.
"That's so true, Doug."
Who is Doug?
This is never answered.
She just wrote this on my wall.
I think it's someone's aunt.
But basically, let's
see, how am I on time?
OK, I have to wrap it up.
So I'll skip this
next-- OK, well I
just wanted to do
real quick, these
are some new words
that I learned today,
just to help you guys.
I was like, I need to
learn some new slang words,
so just that so everyone
can learn with me.
Here's some.
Netflix and chill, if you
want to casually hook up
with someone.
Snatched, on point,
it's the new fleek.
Fleek is done.
You heard it here first.
There's extra, where
you're trying too hard
or being over the top.
Ship is two people you want to
be in a relationship together.
Like if you're like, I
ship Kevin and Tracy,
then that means you want
them to find true love.
Sleeved, someone with
undeserved confidence.
And OTP, one true
pairing, a couple
you are emotionally invested in.
Clearly a lot of these
are sort of female driven.
But here's the twist,
one of them I made up.
Care to wager a guess?
-Sleeved.
-Sleeved, you're right.
OK, I've got to go back to the
drawing board with my attempts
to influence language.
And then, basically, in
conflusion, which is a word
I made up that means
confused conclusion,
because I don't think I really
came to any true points here.
This is quote from Jay Z,
known wordsmith and rapper,
"remind yourself, nobody built
like you, you design yourself."
And that can be about you,
or it can be about language.
Think about it.
OK that's going to be if for me.
Thanks guys.
Thanks a lot.
-OK, let's do that again.
Aparna Nancherla, people.
I think what's
going to happen now
is they're going to bring
up chairs and things,
and we're going to all sit here.
I'm not sure that's a chair.
I believe that's a stool,
but I think we're going to--
-It is.
-84,000 Twitter followers.
I mean, again applause.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
-While we're getting
ready to sit down--
-Yeah.
-Why is your Twitter
handle aparnapkin?
-Oh, aparnapkin?
It's because I was on Twitter
before people were using it
as a professional tool.
So I was still trying to be cute
when I came up with my handle.
It still haunts me today.
-You define yourself
as a crumpled napkin?
-Yes.
-That's sad.
-Is it?
-I'm not sure.
We'll discuss.
But first, I want to let people
know who's up here with us.
Glenda Carpio, professor
of English and African
and African-American
Studies at Harvard,
and she's got a terrific
book, Laughing Fit to Kill,
in which she's looked at
comedy and through a very
interesting filter of race.
And so we're going
to get started here.
Why a crumpled napkin?
You're not a crumpled napkin.
-No I think I just
like it because it's
like something that you
absorb things and ideas,
and then you're muddled, but
you're sifting through things.
-OK
-Yeah, and that's what you do.
I was noticing one of your
tweets, you talk about emojis.
You sent one out, "why is
there only one white snowman?"
-I know.
It's a real problem.
-Real problem, so the
overarching conversation
of the two days is how language
changes over time, maybe
because as issues of
sexuality and gender
maybe bend the language a bit.
When you're doing your
comedy, do you feel it evolve?
I was thinking, for
instance, might it
be OK to do a joke now
about Caitlyn Jenner,
because she's one
and she's powerful,
but it might not have
been OK a while back?
-Yeah, I mean, I think comedy
is very influenced by time.
I remember reading
an article where
it was someone was studying
how soon after a tragedy,
like a Twitter
joke, became funny.
Like it wasn't funny hours after
this natural disaster happened.
But then it was like, he
looked at it five weeks later
and it was like,
then it was popular.
So I do think there's an arc
of people's emotional journey
of being able to accept
something as funny once they've
sort of distanced themselves
from the grief, or the tragedy,
or the struggle of something.
-Well the struggle,
and that brings
to mind something I wanted
to talk to you both about.
Glenda, I know you want to throw
out some thoughts about this,
the Oscars.
Did you all see Chris
Rock do the Oscars?
I mean, right in the opening
monologue, Glenda, there
he is saying, you might wonder
why we weren't protesting
not enough blacks previously.
Well back in the
day we were too busy
getting raped and lynched
to care who won best
Oscar for documentary short.
I mean that was hilarious, but
talk about that, well when it's
time for something.
-Well a statement
people hear often
about comedy is that comedy
is tragedy plus time,
but racial inequality in
America is not over, right?
So if there's no time,
so it's constantly
floating between tragedy
and comedy, right?
So the moment in
which Chris Rock
says that, it's a moment
that some feel the tragedy
is still there, still so urgent.
It's not ready for comedy,
and others feel differently.
People laugh and out of
synchronicity, right,
from different vantage points.
But I think that's one of
the most powerful aspects
about humor, is that it
doesn't always just entertain.
It makes you feel
incredibly uncomfortable.
-Well he then kept going.
I mean after he talked
about African-Americans
getting raped and lynched,
we're too busy, uneasy laugh.
And then he says, when
your grandmother's swinging
from a tree, you don't care.
He just kept going and
kept going all night.
-Yeah.
-In fact, you featured a skit
of his in one of your books,
I think.
-Yeah, I mean he was
talking about when
slaves go on vacation.
It's like--
-Should we laugh?
-You go around to
the well, and you
meet the other slave who's
also taking a vacation by going
around the well, you know?
I mean one of the things
about comedy, about races,
and especially about
labor, it's like, again,
the discussion of reparation is
still very much alive, right?
Wall Street was the place
where that New York slave trade
market was on.
Literally the
geographical space, right?
Wall Street itself, the wall,
was built by slaves, right?
Nearby there's an
African burial, right?
So there's the fact
of America been built
by slave labor is true, right?
And so riffing on
taking a vacation
if you're a slave in
the now with Chris Rock,
and this is partly
one of the things
I wanted to talk
to you about, which
is one of the things
about Chris Rock that's
really amazing as a comedian
is that he, like Richard Pryor,
is this little body
with this voice.
And the contrast
between the lightness
of his body, the things he
says, and the voice itself, I
think also makes for a very
pungent kind of comedy,
you know?
-Do you think about your
physicality when you're--
-Yeah, but I don't
think it's as-- it's
more of the thing of you're
being perceived sort of outside
in, whereas when
you're performing
you're sort of
thinking inside out.
So I don't take it
into consideration
when I'm thinking
through my act.
But I think often
it's put on you.
Like identifiers are put
on you as a performer.
-Well you acknowledge that.
I think I just dinged, sorry.
Well you acknowledge-- sorry.
-Are you texting someone?
-I was tweeting
your whole thing.
It was great.
But you had knowledge that,
if I'm reading correctly,
when you come out do
your regular stand up,
you kind of say
something like, I know.
-Yeah.
-What are you saying I know to?
-Just because people
have an expectation
of what they think
a stand up comedian
should look like, or what a
performer should look like.
And I think I had performed
enough times that I sort of was
like, OK well I'm
just going to address
that so I can move on to what
I actually want to talk about.
And it's like OK, I get it.
I don't like what you
think I should look like.
-I know, Mindy Kaling and me.
-Yeah.
-Right, that's it.
But let's find out about you.
The daughter of two doctors.
Did I understand, you
actually chose between West
Point and Amherst College?
-Yeah.
-That's funny.
-I know.
-That's funny, isn't it?
-Really pushing the
indecisiveness of myself
to a bit.
-Which one, by the way?
-Did I go?
Amherst.
-Amherst, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, I don't
think there would be here
if I went to West Point.
-Well what did that
tell us about you?
Indecisive, but what more
did the tell us about you?
-I think just that
I think I have
distinct ideas of identities
I want to inhabit.
I was interested in
West Point as a kid
because I was really interested
in leadership and survival,
and for some reason
I was fixated on,
if I was dropped in the middle
of the woods, could I hack it?
I had that, and
then I had like, I
want to lose myself in a book.
Like so I had these
two sort of identities,
and I think I just had trouble--
-So you were basically a
comedian from the get go.
-Yeah, I mean it all
was in my head, too.
Because it is like it comes in
a sort of unexpected package,
so I think it surprises people.
-Yeah, I know
Glenda, before, one
of these you want to talk
about is language and the most
prominent women that
we're seeing right now,
Hillary Clinton.
What are some of the questions
that are being raised for you?
-She's so stiff, right?
I mean, and so lacks a
sense of self comedy.
I mean not that
she has to have it,
but what does it mean to
hold the platform as a woman?
I think you can
become that stiff.
One of the things that was
immediately funny to me
by your set up was doing
lecturing as a woman.
I mean, especially
when I started here,
when I was fresh
out of grad school,
I looked like a
grad student, right?
So getting up on the
podium to lecture
was already a kind
of funny situation.
I had to perform the idea of
a Harvard professor, right?
And I didn't look the part.
What I loved about
your piece was how you
did like the fake etymology.
The whole thing, the
whole idea, of a genre
of the lecture that
people expect, and you
twisted it around.
Thinking about Hillary
Clinton, what kind of scripts
does she have to
follow, you know?
What is as a political animal?
How does she have to hold back?
How does she have to--
I mean you were saying,
what if a woman was saying
the same things that Drumpf
is saying, you know?
-Well yeah, I mean what
if a woman came out
and she was older, in her
70s, with wild graying hair,
and she talked in
exclamation points like that.
-We looked up at the mash up
of Drumpf's and Clinton's face.
-You've seen it?
-If you want to be
terrorized, you go.
If you have the kind
of perverse desire to--
-They've mashed
their faces together.
-Yeah, it's horrible.
-But, I mean, did you feel
this ever as a comedian?
Because we were talking
about how Hillary Clinton,
in many ways-- she comes out
and it's this wonderful moment.
And I've been privileged to meet
her, personally, many times,
and she's loose and
sweet and small.
And just the completely-- but
you feel as if she's being
forced into jackets, and
pantsuits, and a certain--
-Horrible pantsuits.
-Kind of thing, so
that she'll come out.
I mean, the first thing, if you
win a primary, the first thing,
you walk on the stage,
and people are cheering.
Would you say,
immediately, thank you,
I am going to build a ladder.
Is that the first
thing you'd say?
No, you'd say, oh,
isn't this great or wow.
But if feels like she's been
robbed of that language.
-Yeah, I mean I also feel
like women, in general,
are fed so many
contradictory messages.
At the end, it does
drive you crazy.
And you're like, I
don't know how to be.
I'm just going to be a robot.
I'll just be a robot so
no one can criticize.
-Well another thing we
wanted to ask you about
is, remember in August
when Naomi Wolf wrote
a piece in The Guardian
about vocal fry?
Some of you familiar with that?
It was a criticism of
young women in particular.
They show up a lot on
This American Life,
And they talk like that,
and they have vocal fry.
And Naomi felt that
this was just an affect,
and that young women
should get over it,
that it was demeaning to them.
And it was much like
it wa-- she said
it was like a valley girl who
had gone to a rave the night
before and lost her voice.
Well I called a
professor at Oxford,
her name escapes me
right now, but she's
a feminist and a linguistic
professor in the UK.
And I thought she was going
to say, yes it's important,
much like up talk at
the end of sentences.
And instead she said, do
not do this to young women,
because it's just like shaming
them for the way they dress.
And don't shame
the way they talk.
And further, young
women change language.
They're some of the leaders
in changing language.
You had some thoughts
about that, that we--
-This is a broad
generalization, but it
works for ethnic groups,
racialized groups,
there's a standard
way of speaking
which is often connect to
a standard race or class.
I mean the way that
people in Europe
have a sense of
social difference
is dialect and accents, right?
The way we do it here
is phenotype, right?
And we do it phenotype
and language, right?
And so it's gender, race.
We hear all of that in
the way people speak.
-I realize I love to
say, "and I'm all."
I love that.
He was all this
and I was all that.
I love it.
That came from a young woman.
I interview Nobel
Peace Prize winners
and they begin their
sentence with so.
You know, so your
thoughts on that.
Speak more as this woman
that I'm talking about.
-Yeah no, I agree with that.
I agree with not shaming
women for how they talk.
And just language in itself
is such a fluid changing thing
that I think to put
restrictions on how people talk,
or how they sound, is such
a way of holding people
down or silencing them.
Of being like, oh
well how you talk
is really annoying to everyone,
so maybe don't talk as much.
That's basically what
you're saying to women.
You're like, don't
talk, we don't like it.
I'm like, I thought
we were past that.
We can vote, you know?
-Well it's like the
perennial question
that people often get asked,
women get asked, in comedies.
Are women funny?
It's an insane question
that keeps getting asked.
Really the under commentary
is, are you human?
-Yeah.
Its current now, or I guess
we're in the ebb of it,
because it is
like, Amy Schumer--
-Tina Fey.
-Tina Fey, Kristen
Wiig, but it is
like this argument that
comes up like every 17 years,
like cicadas or something,
where it's like, we
have to solve this again.
It's like nothing changed.
-I know, right?
-What about physical
humor, though?
You were saying that
it's still hard--
-I mean, think of
Eddy Murphy, right?
He got on stage.
He came out, and one of
me students in Black Humor
said that he looked like
a human condom, right?
Those leather
outfits that he had,
he was like a walking penis.
He would hold his penis,
you know, and all that.
I mean, it's the kind of stuff
that, if you do that, you are,
as a woman, and it's a totally
different scene, you know?
I mean Wanda Sykes
does a amazing bit
about going to a titty
bar in Florida, right?
And she's amazing in the
physical comedy of it,
but there are very
few women who can
risk that because
it has-- you're
sexualized anyway, right?
But if you draw attention
to it through comedy people
are going to this stop
at the sex and kind
of let go of the humor somehow.
I mean, it's crazy.
I mean, someone like Louis
CK could make comedy out
of his belly, right?
But think about a fat woman
coming out and doing comedy
about a belly, right?
There's so much baggage around
women and their physicalness,
that I think people can't
even really even laugh at it,
you know?
-Yeah, well I think even
between men and women,
specifically in those
I guess binary terms,
I feel like there is a
masculine sense of humor,
and way of being,
and then there's
like a more feminine
sort of character
driven and subtle
nuanced way of joking.
And I do feel like both
male and female comedians
weave between the two, but
I do think that it is often
female comedians are
expected to adapt
more masculine
traits and qualities,
whereas more men
don't cross over.
Because I will see sometimes
men in the audience
check out during a
female comedian's set,
but it's only because her style
is not the same like setup
punch line, set up punch
line, set up punch line.
And they're just like,
I don't understand.
And they like sort of,
this is not for me.
But it's like, it shouldn't
be like female comedy is
like a niche thing.
We're all human, so it's
like it's all one spectrum,
but it is like that is what
stand up started as chiefly,
so that's what like
people think stand up is.
-But it's crazy though,
because if you really
think about comedies,
let's just take
the example of American culture,
some of was minstrel stage,
and so much of it was like
people crossdressing, right?
-Yeah.
-So it was like white men
playing black and playing
female, right?
And so it's all of this getting
very close to all these taboos
that are then all be
constantly alive, right?
And so when you have to stand
up without the minstrel set up,
it's interesting that we
can't go to those taboos,
or that they're alive on
stage in a very different way.
-Right.
-I just had a couple
questions, because again we're
going to have a performance
from ImprovBoston,
which we can't wait.
And I think, I don't know
if I've got this right,
but I think that
they're actually
going to be playing off some of
the things we've said up here.
Oh joy.
-I somehow am thinking parody.
-And also we're going
to get your questions.
But I just had one, every
word that you spoke,
you may not want to let
us inside your process,
but every word that you spoke
when you did this was perfect.
It was.
-Whoa.
-It was.
It was, wasn't it?
-I'm going to really have
to dig into that therapy
exercising, accepting
a complement.
-Breathe.
No but it was.
And so is it is not because you
spent hours making sure that--
do you craft it that way?
-I mean, I feel like
stand ups have--
someone come to it from a more
sort of organic of like talking
their ideas out on stage.
I think I have a more writerly
mind and sort of control issues
where I have to know what I'm
going to say for the most part
ahead of time.
So I think I do latch
on to like phrases
and I like love language
and I love word play,
so I think I sort of
build my jokes and ideas
around just like a set of
words, or a set of phrases.
So I think that sort of
runs through what I do.
-And this was a
language lecture.
But I just loved how
you seem to love words.
What's that one that's over,
because I didn't know that it--
-Fleek.
-I'm sorry?
-I'm fleek.
-What?
What is it?
-It's OK.
I was, when I made
that slide, I was
like I don't know if you're
reading the room right.
-No, I'm not the room.
What does it mean?
-On fleek is like on point.
Like if you're like--
-Tom Ashbrook.
I'm sorry.
That's a Boston-- sorry.
Go ahead.
-But yeah, it look
like it's spot on.
-Oh, but if I start
using it now, it's--
-It's usually more about
someone's appearance
or something.
-But it's over.
That word is over.
-Yeah, apparently it's snatched.
-And one last thing,
do either of you,
you work with words, you work
with words, I work with news,
and work with words that way.
We had a crazy day today.
I don't know if you know.
Mitt Romney's got up and
excoriated Donald Trump.
Unbelievable, and
then Donald Trump
got up and excoriated him back.
And I was working,
trying to, because we
update for different time zones,
and we're trying to listen.
And I looked up at
one point, and you
know how CNN has the banner
that goes across the bottom,
and it said, Trump colon,
and I ruined my carpet
endorsing Romney."
I know, and apparently he had
a fundraiser for Mitt Romney,
and people come with muddy
shoes, and ruined his carpet.
And so he'd got a
whole screen about how
he should bill Mitt Romney
for his carpet from the time
he'd helped.
And then you could tell someone
at CNN was just like lost
their mind.
So Trump, I ruined my
carpet endorsing Romney.
Do you ever find it's
like too hard to be funny,
because real life's so funny?
-It's like a joke on a joke.
-What do you do with that?
That, he really said.
-I know.
I know.
I mean, it's funny.
With all of that going on right
now, it is like, as a comedian,
it's interesting.
Part of it is almost like we
are living in a fever dream.
And like do you
make jokes about it,
or you just like let's us
put cold towels on our faces?
But I still think
we can make a joke
on-- as a comedian your
goal is to heighten
whatever the reality is.
So I think if he said
that about his carpet,
what else would he say it about.
There's always some
direction to go.
-Well that is just the
set up for a sexual joke.
-Yeah.
-Like, I ruined my carpet.
-Yeah there's something
distasteful there.
-So weird.
-What?
-OK let's stop there.
Glenda Carpio, Aparna
Nancherla, wonderful.
So want we're going to do is,
we're going to take our seats,
and we're going to invite
members of ImprovBoston
to come on up.
And guys, why don't we
start making the transition?
We'll move the chairs.
ImprovBoston, ladies
and gentlemen,
have you been to Central Square?
One of the great
shining jewels of Boston
over there in Porter
Square, and they also
visit hospitals in
different places,
taking their fun stuff to
places where it really lands.
But I have a feeling, now
they're going to skewer us.
And so, ImprovBoston.
-Thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Robin.
We are ImprovBoston
My name is Deana.
-I'm Kelly.
-Hey, I'm Greg.
-My name is Corey.
-I'm Sara.
-Rosena.
-And I'm Mike.
-Thank you so much for your
smattering of applause.
So Aparna is a brilliant
stand up and a writer,
and as Robin said, her
words were perfection.
So Aparna spent a lot
of time making sure
that every word she says up here
was going to be exactly right.
We do a different
style of comedy
called improvisation, where
we haven't prepared anything
at all, and we
have no idea what's
going to come out of our mouths.
-However, it's still perfect.
-Oh well, we'll let them
be the judge, Corey.
We hope that's the case,
and we assume it will be,
but the audience is
ultimately the judge of that.
So what we're going to
do is an improvised set.
And as Robin
mentioned, we're going
to take our inspiration tonight
from what we have all just
experienced.
So we're going to use
what Aparna had to say.
We're going to use what
Glenda and Robin had to say,
and other information
about the conference.
And we're going to be
completely making everything up
on the spot.
So what you're about to see
has never happened before.
I assure you it will
never happen again.
Everything is going to be
improvised just for you,
and that means we
may need your help.
So throughout our 23
minutes and 45 seconds,
we might be coming to you
all for some suggestions.
We've got some microphones.
We can run right
out to the audience.
All of you look
afraid right now.
It's fine.
I promise, it will
be completely fine.
So let's just get a little
bit warmed up, right?
So just for everyone, I'll
just ask what your name.
And on the count of
three, you'll yell it out.
It'll be very easy.
What is your, one, two, three?
All of you are name Jennifer.
I don't know.
That was a terrible question.
I couldn't hear any of it.
You're all named Glenda now.
So we're going to
start our set tonight.
We just heard some
really inspiring things
by Glenda and Aparna and Robin.
What is, from someone
in the audience,
something that you heard in
their discussion, one word that
stuck out to you?
This is the language
conference after all.
-Carpet.
-Great.
-Thank you.
-Carpet.
-It's just, it's ruined.
The carpet is completely
ruined right now.
-I feel like this
is like the time
that I spilled coffee on my
pant suit and no one told me.
And--
-Do you know how many
pant suits I have ruined
endorsing political candidates?
-You've got blond hair.
-Yeah.
-I got blond hair.
-Yeah, you want
start a boy band.
-I also have blond
hair, just saying.
-I'm just going to rest
this joke here for a second.
In five hours, it'll be funny.
-Hello, my name is Sara.
I will be playing the part
of your professor today.
I might not look
like your professor,
but that's who I will
be playing today,
because I am a performer.
-Hello, my name is Deana.
I will be playing the
part of a student today.
-OK, quiet.
It's my turn.
Professor Ship is-- did
you have a question?
-I just wanted to say that
I actually went to Emerson,
so it's a miracle they're
letting me in this building
right now.
-Yes.
-You guys, several times I was
telling you about things that I
wanted to tell you about.
-Hey, excuse me--
-I just wanted to say--
-Sometimes--
-Can you please not.
You're literally
shaming me right now.
-I ordered a coffee and it
only came as a latte soy upside
down frappuccino.
-I was thinking that it would
be good if we all were to just
get--
-Freeze, Corey and
Sara, switch characters.
-So you were saying in a
normal human speech pattern--
-Right.
-My thesis is about several
things that have to do with
comedy--
-As the head of--
-Freeze.
Kelly and Sara switch character.
--[INAUDIBLE] I didn't
get a piece of corn.
-So what you're saying is--
-Freeze.
Greg and Dina,
switch characters.
-It's OK.
-Are you upset?
I'm having a hard time.
What the emotion?
Do you need-- do you feel--
-Mrs. Clinton, I just
need you to understand,
as our country's first major
contender to be president,
who is a woman, we are so
honored to have you bring--
-I'm sorry, I have Mrs.
Clinton's update ready.
-It's just, we want
you to be warm.
-Enjoy version 2.3.
-OK.
-Freeze, every time
Miss Clinton speaks,
she can only speak
in a certain number
of words between one and 30.
How many words?
-Five.
-I heard five.
Every time Miss Clinton
speaks, it's in five words.
No more, no less.
Continue.
-Mrs. Clinton, we need you
to be warm and also cold.
And we need you to be hard,
and we need to be soft.
And we need you to be strong
and weak, all at the same time.
We need to be vulnerable
but impenetrable,
and we need you to be
an achiever, but also
an underachiever.
We want you to be successful
and unsuccessful all at once.
We don't want you to
have too much experience,
but we need you to have
all the experience.
-How are you all doing out--
-Do we have another update
for Mrs. Clinton, or is this--
-That was unfortunately
the last one.
-OK.
-This is Clinton 4.0.
-OK, well I'm sure
the people would love
to hear what you have to say.
So I know I have some
questions for Mrs. Clinton.
-Mrs. Clinton, excuse me, in as
many words as you possibly can,
what is your vision for America?
-America is a place.
-That is true.
America is a place.
Does anyone have a question for
Mrs. Clinton, from the audience
here?
Would like to ask Mrs.
Clinton a question?
-Question?
Any question at all?
Any Question at all?
-I've got one.
-Yeah, we've go one here.
-Yeah, so what would
be the first thing you
do when you get into office?
-Very good question.
-Great question,
more Ellen Show.
Woot.
-Finger on the pulse of America.
-Woot.
Woot.
-Great, I think we've got
another question here.
-Oh good, because she'll
woot for rest of the hour.
-Who will your first
cabinet appointment be?
-Great question.
Cabinet appointment.
-Cabinet appointment,
first cabinet appointment.
-My husband, Bill, of course.
-Mixed reaction from the room,
not sure that's a good idea.
-If we're going to be
fielding questions here,
I only think it's
appropriate that we
have everybody involved.
It's me, Donald.
You didn't recognize it?
-Oh, I mean the--
-It's spot on.
Spot on.
Well, does anyone have a
question for Mr. Drumpf, today?
Who has a question
for Mr. Drumpf?
No one wants to talk
to-- right here.
-You said earlier that you
were upset about your rug,
could you tell us a
little more about that?
-I had a perfectly
nice finished basement.
Beautiful, beautiful
finished basement.
Had a corner bar and everything.
Muddy feets all over place
-Only rug I see on head.
-Yep.
-Oh my goodness,
face is on fleek.
-You must be Tom Ashbrook.
-You're so snatched.
-Are you two ship?
Shipping.
-OTC is what we are.
We're trying to get
together at this party.
-Guys, what about your sleeved?
-Nice try, nice try, that
was mad extra though.
-I'm not sure about the
Halloween costume I got.
I mean, it was the
last one at the store.
It's a walking penis.
-Fix the hat.
Switch it around.
Put it around on the other side.
Put it around to the other side.
Yep, I like it.
This is less
aggressive, I feel like.
-Does it-- oh there we go.
-You don't have to be
sexy for Halloween.
-You don't have
to be sexy at all.
-I'm just trying
to have a costume.
It's the only costume they had.
-Freeze.
Greg, let's hear your
Oscar winning moment.
-There's a lot of people at
this party I want to impress.
I don't have a lot of friends
and well it's a costume party,
and you can't go to a costume
party not in a costume.
So I said, what
costumes do you got?
And he said, well it's the day
of Halloween, not much, man.
He said, I got one
for you, my friend.
I got one.
It's a walking penis costume.
I said, how much?
And he said, the
deposit was $350.
I said, I only got
250, will it work?
He said, sure but you
don't get the balls.
-Back to the scene
-Son, you've always
been what we've wanted.
You don't need a costume.
-Proud of you just
the way you are.
I would ditch that dick
outfit, and I would move on
to something else.
Like being just
you, perfect you.
-No costume at all.
-None.
-Except the one that
I wear every day.
You know, the way
society views me.
It's the costume that I wear.
-Right, your mask.
-Right, it's the
mask that I put on.
-How they make you.
-There's really no way
to remove it, right,
it's the way that I'm viewed.
-Most people don't
understand it anyways.
-A lot of people are
unfamiliar with semiotics.
I definitely am.
Went to Harvard.
-And they're making assumptions
about you all the time.
-Right
-People make assumptions
about you all the time.
-Freeze.
Kelly, let's hear your
Oscar winning moment.
-Just want my child
to feel empowered,
to be whoever they want to be.
I want ze to grow up and
feel happy about the person
that they've become.
I feel like it just takes a
little bit of courage, and just
the basic common sense to
be the human that you are,
and that I know you can be.
-Just takes a bit of courage?
-Just a little bit.
-Back to the scene.
-Now clean this
up, because mommy
doesn't like a messy floor.
-Sweetie, please don't go
see Fifty Shades of Nonsense.
Send.
-I just got the weirdest
text from my mom.
-Dot send.
-Oh she means it.
She put a period in there.
-Whoa.
-Yeah, Yeah, I know.
-Does that say I just acted out
Fifty Shades of Grey with dad?
-Yes that's exactly
what it says.
-That can't be what
she meant to type.
-Is that what you meant?
-Space, space,
space, space, space.
-She's typing.
-My thoughts are very loud.
Send.
-Tell her I like
chicken pot pie.
-Send.
-I don't know if they're
asking me to dinner,
or what is happening here.
-Take a picture of my earlobe.
It's gotten bigger
than the other.
-Oh God, what is that body part?
-I don't know.
I don't know.
-What is that.
-I don't know.
-I feel like we're really
communicating, right?
-No, no, no, no, no,
no, you guys, it's fine.
We just got dropped in
the middle of the woods.
Go read your books.
I'm just going to build
this fire by myself, OK?
-Would it help you to know
that I'm reading a book
in the Little House
on the Prairie series,
and there might be some
valuable information about--
-That would help--
-How to live in the wilderness.
-Would it help, or
just be more ironic,
if I burned this copy
of Fahrenheit 451?
-That would be both ironic
and hopeful, Chad, yes.
-Look.
-What?
-We didn't all apply to West
Point together for no reason,
OK?
-Hey, I have a safety
school of Amherst college.
-Again, I just really
want to go to Emerson.
-West Point was our dream.
That's why we're here.
-Sometimes dreams change.
-Say it again, Chad.
-One more time.
-Sometimes dreams change.
(SINGING) When I
look all around,
I think that this
used to be my joy.
-(SINGING) His joy.
His joy.
-(SINGING) But now I
know with you by my side,
I don't need to
go to West Point.
-(SINGING) West Point.
West Point.
-(SINGING) Sometimes
changes happen.
Sometimes we change.
Sometimes changes happen.
-(SINGING) I'm a bookworm
reading Little House.
-(SINGING) Little House.
Little House.
-(SINGING) Just a little
house, and it's on a Prairie.
This particular
book in the series
isn't helpful, because it's
mostly about my sister, Mary.
Things change.
-(SINGING) Things change.
-(SINGING) Things can change.
-(SINGING) Sometimes,
sometimes things can change.
-(SINGING) On this
trip, I brought not one,
two but three joints.
It was my goal to
get into West Point.
-(SINGING) West Point.
West Point.
-(SINGING) With you clowns,
me, you, you, and you.
All of us, and looking
around, there's
no way out, no
car, train, or bus.
Sometimes things change.
-(SINGING) Sometimes.
-(SINGING) Things change.
(SPEAKING) Thank you, Judy.
Thank you.
-You're welcome.
-(SINGING) Sometimes
things, sometimes people,
sometimes the world, things--
-(ALL SINGING) Change.
-All right, if you guys
will just have a seat.
Thank you so much
for joining me.
Just going to ask you a few--
oop, sorry, that's my phone.
-Verily.
Verily she is a
saucy pomegranate.
I swear is a spruced plum.
Well I've forgotten the
line, but you get it.
-Play to the pit, sir.
Play to the pit.
-Well poops and fun and
beavers and chuckles.
-Well done, Miss.
-Yes, word from the
king's come down.
Everyone on the court has died.
It's very tragic, very sad.
And my wife is
still a sprickly--
-Geoffry, come in
here please, Geoffry.
Your offending a lot of people
when you're saying these--
-It's the script.
It's the script.
-The script says stewed prune.
-Well thank you, I've
been calling for line
all freaking night.
-Do you understand
the sort of people
that you've offended thus far?
-What?
Who?
Who's offended by--
-Tell me the last
thing you said.
-It was, I believe it was
something about pears.
-You've offended all
blonde haired men.
Think about it.
-I will.
I apologize.
One more time.
What's the line?
Hit me with the line.
One more time, I've
forgotten again.
-You've got it deep down.
-Nope, I've already
forgotten it.
-Whenceforth--
-Oh, you've forgotten it too.
Oh yes.
Yes.
-No.
-Yes.
-Never.
-Blood hell, it's
kumquat serve spot.
Is that it?
-We're all trying.
We're all trying to gain an
understanding of the language
and how it works today.
I get this.
But we have to be true.
Now say the line.
-Very well.
It's not soggy plums, but
I think it's soggy plums.
-It's not.
It sounds like--
-Seat belt. Cut it.
I'm so sorry.
-I just want to say,
I just want to say,
your words are perfection.
-Thank you.
Take the compliment.
-It just keeps going.
It just keeps going.
Keep going.
More.
Yes.
Yes, that's it.
It's perfect thing
after perfect thing.
-Keep this going, I'm just
going to change the recording.
That's my laptop.
-Play to the pit.
-OK.
-Pumpkin spice lattes
and all good rubbish.
I don't know.
-How are these now
for the fellow.
What are you this here
burnt marshmallow?
-Corey, take the couplet back.
-Oh my.
-What must I say there sitting
on this lap, for you are
just one extra salty hot dog.
-Corey, take that couplet back.
-Sure, When I said you
must have been the lob,
I want to skewer you,
you piece of shish kabob.
-Corey, take that couplet
back, but this time rap it.
-All right, yeah, yo
I'm looking at you,
but I don't want to make you
cry, because you a nice piece
of fluffy apple pie.
Yeah, I'm saying it's a dream,
and you're just some piece
of nice vanilla ice cream.
[INAUDIBLE] I'm
saying they are true,
And I just know that you
are different kinds of food.
I'm going to tell
you, I'll tell you
this quick, pour up a nice
glass of that little liqu- or.
It gets you in a funk.
-What's this I hear?
Oh is this guy a
rapper Shakespeare?
-To the pit I say, I'm
just a portly milk maid.
-From whence from
the belt and I jam,
I'm still saying
princess of Bellingham.
And I don't even say
that I'm not gentry, oh,
but I'm just helping.
Oh what has happened to
me, I think I'm dying.
I think I might be,
drowning in the ocean.
What is this [INAUDIBLE]
I feel like a basket
of dried up figgy pudding.
-I got, I got expelled.
-You did?
Is it because your
label fell off?
-Maybe, but they said it-- one
of the teachers told me to man
up, and I told him--
-What?
-Yeah, so I told
him to woman up.
-Yes.
-That is how I
raised my daughter.
-Thank you.
-Man up?
-Right.
-We push children out.
-Yeah, that's what women do.
-That's power.
-Thank you.
-So woman up.
-So that's what I said.
I got right in his
face, and I was
like, you've never pushed a
baby out of your parts, buddy.
Who's tough now?
And then I started
naming the parts, which
may be while I got expelled.
-That was a little far,
but I'm proud of you.
-Thank you.
-Because that's really
nice, but I think
I need to have a meeting
with your principal.
-Oh.
-We need to have a conversation.
-I know what's going to happen.
He's going to cry.
-Thank you for joining me.
-Welcome.
-What is the meaning
of expelling my child?
of anything really?
What does expelled mean?
-She's a third grader
and she said labia.
-You should be proud
that I know what that is.
-That's right.
This is America.
-Go on.
-It is the land of free speech.
And my daughter had
something to say, and she--
-This is a common
misinterpretation.
Free speech means that you
can say whatever you want,
but you need to face the
repercussions of what
you do inevitably say.
-What?
That's the definition
of-- that's
literally what free speech is.
That's how it's defined.
-Excuse me.
-Wait.
-I will not stand in America
that will not let my daughter--
-Well than, have a seat.
-Good point.
My point is, I raised
her to speak her mind.
-Yeah.
-I raised her to
be a strong lady.
-Yeah.
-OK, and she's going
to come here tomorrow.
-Yeah.
-Because you're going to
revoke that expulsion.
-I'm here right now.
-And she is going to speak
her mind all day, all day.
Matter of fact, she should
have your job, Mr. Principal.
-Yeah.
-Again, she's a third grader.
I don't think that
would be wise.
And I respect your
fervor here, but can we
agree that you're mad
that I said man up,
which arguably is me
exercising my own free speech?
-Wait a minute.
-I'm just saying is all.
I'm just saying, it's a kid
phrase that I like to use,
just saying.
-Hey, Rosena?
-Yes.
-I just wanted to say, you
said expulsion earlier.
Your words are perfection.
-Oh my gosh, thank you, Sara.
-Hey Rosena, I wanted
to call that out too,
but I didn't know if
it was appropriate.
-Totally appropriate.
-But you're perfect.
-Thank you, Corey.
-You're welcome.
-Hey, Kelly?
-Hey, Sara.
-You know what you're
reminding me of right now?
-What?
-That Kim K graduation emoji.
-You know what that
makes me feel like doing?
-What?
-The Kim K cry emoji.
-You know what that
makes me feel like doing?
That Kim K
highlighting emoji that
exists for some
reason, where you
see all of the makeup on my
face, but in different parts.
-I think that's actually
a contouring emoji,
which implies that her
face is fat in some way.
-I thought it was a kitty cat
emoji, and those were stripes.
-I think it's just another
way for people to make people
feel bad about themselves.
-You know what, I think it's
just another way people change.
-I'm not clear on emojis.
-Hey, Sara.
-Yeah?
-Say that again.
-I will.
People change.
-Say it one more time.
-One more time.
-(SINGING) People change.
-(ALL SINGING) People change.
-(SINGING) You might think
they're going to say one thing
but they don't.
-(SINGING) People change.
-(ALL SINGING) People change.
-(SINGING) You want to
say one thing, but you--
-(SINGING) People change.
-(RAPPING) Yeah, we've
got something to teach.
Please express your
freedom to all free speech.
It doesn't matter what you say
or what you will recover, just
know that there's repercussions
that you must suffer.
-(SINGING) People change.
-Thank you so much.
We are ImprovBoston.
Come see us at our home theater
in Central Square, Cambridge.
We're going to kick
it back over to Robin,
and enjoy the rest
of the evening.
-How scary is that?
I was starting to sweat.
-People do tell us that a lot,
that they sweat watching us,
that they're nervous for us.
That because we
don't know what we're
going to say, a lot of people
cringe when we first start.
They're rooting for us to
succeed, which is great.
We do a lot of kids
classes, and the thing
we tell the kids when
they're getting nervous
before they come out
to do their shows
is, nerves and
excitement are actually
the same chemical in the body.
So just convince yourself that
you're actually really excited,
and then let that propel
you on to the stage.
So we are nervous,
but mostly we're
just fooling ourselves that
it's going to be a good time.
And then it is.
-Well it's also
probably because,
if there's no script, who
knows what's going to come out,
which means that who knows
what you're thinking.
I mean it's also a
reflection, and the audience
knows that there's chaos.
It's entropy, right?
That's what humor does,
it allows entropy.
And improv is all
about that, right,
letting the unconscious
out as well.
So you sign up for
the unexpected,
both from the side of
the stage, but also
from the side of the audience.
-I personally find that
to be a great relief.
Tonight, I get to
moonlight as the pianist,
but my full time job is artistic
director of the theater.
So we think a lot about this
idea of being in the moment.
And for me, I was trained
as a traditional actor,
and having a script
is terrifying
because there's a right
answer, there's a wrong answer.
You either do it
right or you don't.
And in improvisation,
there is no right answer.
There is no wrong answer.
There's only what
we create together.
So that sense of, oh we're
going to go out on stage
and we're going to
have a dialogue.
That's simple enough.
You're always
prepared to do that.
-Well there's also going-- you
open up yourself for a flop.
-Yeah.
-Richard Pryor did
a lot of improved
before he became
Richard Pryor, right?
He found his voice
by doing improv,
which is a way of kind of
failing and finding the voice,
and doing that, right?
But it takes a lot of courage
to fail in front of everybody.
-Not that you did.
Ever.
-Thank you, Robin.
-We probably did a little bit.
-I'm sweating now.
-I do think that's important,
though, the idea of failure
being something that we
actually strive toward.
The idea that we're not
taking risks as comedians,
then we're not
actually doing our job.
And particularly in
a setting like this,
where we know that there's
this big overarching theme,
and it's really important,
and what everyone is here
to do tonight and tomorrow
is to talk about something
so serious, and so
important to what's
happening in society right now.
There's a lot of pressure
on us walking into tonight.
We don't want to offend anyone.
What if we say the wrong words?
What if we get it all wrong?
And the thing that we try
to keep in mind tonight
is, the second we're in our
heads about getting it wrong
and saying the wrong thing, we
won't be able to say anything.
-You won't be funny either.
-Right, so just see
what happens, and hope
that, if we've
offended someone, they
understand that it
was unintentional,
and come talk to us after,
and we'll apologize.
And we'll have a
beer or something.
-Or they'll punch you.
-Or that, yeah, maybe.
-You seem very angry at us.
Do you want to talk
about something?
-I was thinking too, that we
were talking about physicality
and women, and here we had a
woman being a penis Halloween
costume.
Beautifully, I might say.
-Thank you so much.
-You're welcome.
-It was my best work.
-Your best work, right.
So a lot of the things we were
talking about just, in comedy.
I just want, Aparna,
do you do improv too?
-Yeah, when I started, I
took improv classes too,
and did that alongside
stand up for a long time.
-What did it do for your--
-I mean, for me, it
was really helpful in,
like you guys were saying, just
letting go the control as much,
and sort of just
exploring where things go.
That's, I think,
the beauty of improv
is you never know where
you're going to end up.
And you sort of trust
the people around you,
and yourself, to know
you'll land on your feet.
-Or not.
-Yeah.
-Don't forget that
we're going to ask you,
if you have questions
for anybody you up here,
to be gathering
them so that we can
do that in just a few minutes.
So you didn't take any notes,
and you remembered more
about our talk than I
remembered about our talk.
-Well here's the great thing,
improvisation is a team sport.
So it wasn't on any one of
us to remember all of it.
Each one of us
grabs something that
resonates with them,
something that speaks to them.
So if we all have a handful of
things, there's seven of us,
so it will feel like we
all remembered all of it.
Yeah that's our secret.
-Another part of the improv
training is active listening.
Most of us go through our
lives and have the experience
of waiting to talk, which
is different than actually
listening.
And so you are, if
you do this year in
and year out, you're learning
to really hone in on,
what is the person next to
me or across from me saying?
How can I listen to that idea?
How can I incorporate that idea?
In improvisation, we're
also interested in the idea
of owning that idea, so
your idea becomes my idea.
The idea of a cell
phone going off
in the middle of moderating
is may be terrifying to you,
but to us it's gold.
Oh there's a piece we can pick
up on, and then we can own it.
-That's what that was.
-And then all of us have
our cell phones going off.
So now we have
this owned concept
that comes through
just really listening
as closely as possible.
-And we also have a notion
that every single word, as
improvisers, is a gift.
Every single word our scene
partner uses is important.
One word can change the
meaning of an entire sentence.
Improvisation is founded
on the idea of a concept
called, yes and.
We say yes to our scene
partners idea, and we add to it.
And the difference between,
yes and, and yes but is
night and day.
There's a huge distance
between yes and, and yes but.
So for us, every
single word matters.
Which is why, for us
to be at a conference
like this when we're talking
about the actual evolution
of language in real
time, is fascinating.
Because as improvisers,
we're having
to key into all
of those changes.
People are coming
to our theater,
and we're asking
for suggestions,
and they're yelling out
words that we may have never
even heard before,
but they're words.
They're real words
that people are using.
So it's important for us
to be actively involved
in the listening and
the conversation.
-With the theater, we serve
the community through laughter.
That's part of our mission
statement in ImprovBoston.
I can tell you, everybody that
performed for you tonight,
the performers, we actually
work a lot with children.
Corey O'Rourke, our wonderful
rap master MC, he and I
both do a lot of the
summer comedy camps.
And last summer, we
would break for lunch,
and have to meet and say, they
said this, this, and this.
I don't know what
those things are.
Did you google them.
I did.
They still don't
make sense to me.
I feel like they're
very inappropriate
and we should be writing
letters home to parents.
-I'm not the only one.
-It's just, it's
moving so quickly,
and keeping up with it
can be very challenging.
-Well that's what
you were talking.
I mean, do you feel you have
to do that as a stand up
comedian, with 84, 86, probably
90,000 followers by now.
Do you feel you have
to be on top of that?
-Well, I think you sort
of find the middle ground
of your point of view
and the world around you,
and your space in it.
And I think sticking to that
is sort of like your guiding
light of where you land.
Because if I only
wanted to play to teens,
then yeah I probably would
be more linked in to slang.
But you sort of learn
from your audiences, too.
You see what works and what
doesn't, and you sort of
adjust accordingly.
-Because it is a real divide.
I mean, I remember when all the
texting and everything started.
For the longest time I thought
LOL meant lots of love.
So I'd been writing my
nieces and nephews like,
oh I really hope you do
well in school today LOL.
I mean, I'm wondering if you
feel that divide in comedy too?
Like, oh there is somebody
out there who really is not
getting what we're doing,
because we are in a language
divide.
I mean, there's a whole
language that's been created.
-I mean, I think that you
have to present yourself
as a person.
And I think that was funny
watching the panel before.
I've know Aparna for a
while, and follow her work,
and that question always does
come up, are women funny?
Nope, they're just people.
They wear pants sometimes.
Be a human first.
I think, be a person, be
relatable, and find your voice,
choose what you want
your voice to be,
and I think that
that's what we should
be doing in life as well.
I think comedians
are gifted and lucky.
And I was talking with a few of
the guests prior to this event,
and I said, it's not
lost on me how lucky
we are that we get
to use words and we
get to present our ideas.
And things inspire us.
We get to share them.
And we get to also
flip them on their side
and find the funny part of it.
-I think the piece of
what Kelly is saying,
about the storytelling
component, is so important.
Before I got to ImprovBoston,
I was with The Second City
in Chicago for about a decade.
And when you get hired to The
Second City, you get a salary,
and you get a subscription
to the Chicago Tribune.
And your goal is to
be as on top of all
of the news and current
events as humanly possible.
And the time I was there,
the newest timeline
was speeding up so quickly.
What Glenda was saying
about the tragedy plus time
equals comedy, well time gets
shorter and shorter and shorter
every year.
And what we were struggling with
at Second City, in those days,
was actually finding the
humanity behind the news story.
You can't just
regurgitate the facts,
because now it takes three
months to produce a Second City
review.
By the time that three
months has elapsed,
the news cycle is old, old, old.
So what you're looking
for is, what is
the humanity behind the news?
How do you create
characters and relationships
that will stand the test
of at least six months,
if not the test of time?
And I think on some level,
even in improvisation,
that's what we're looking for.
What is the humanity?
What is the story?
What is the real human
interest behind this?
And when you can expose
that and explore that,
the audience is going
to be on your side,
even if you're dealing with a
really touchy, edgy material
that maybe not everyone in
the audience is on board with.
If you present
humans interacting,
you have this empathy
and this connection.
And I think it was true for
what Aparna was doing too.
She's just so relatable.
She could say literally almost
anything and I'm, oh yeah.
Oh that's great.
Oh good point, right?
She just draws you.
I think that's really important
as opposed to-- sorry?
-People change.
So maybe tomorrow,
it's not the case.
-It changed right now.
Aparna, we're going to have
to ask you to step down.
-I just think too, that when
you start thinking about words,
and we were before we came
here, is everything starts to
just-- if you can see the humor
in it, like I was tweeting
your last name, which is Carpio,
and it kept coming up carpool.
-Yeah.
-And so it's like, OK.
-Professor Carpool.
-You're Glenda Carpool.
I mean, just going
with it, and going
with where the words, whatever
they are, where they take you.
We've got just a few minutes.
I know you all want to race back
and see the Republican debate.
First time Trump faces
Megyn Kelly, come on.
But what we'd like you to do, we
can put a microphone somewhere.
-Middle aisle.
-Yes middle aisle here.
The great people who are,
by the way, taping this.
This entire event is going
to be able to-- yeah,
so it's going to be, all of it.
Thank you so much.
Going to be running.
So come on on
questions for anybody.
Maybe you've read Glenda's
terrific books, Laughing Fit
to Kill, about comedy through
an African-American prism.
Or if you're a Twitter
follower of Aparna,
or you want to leave.
Fleeing from the microphone.
Oh my god, they're racing.
Witness protection--
-This is that improv
fear everyone has.
I didn't plan a question.
I should go.
They're all sneaking out.
Thank you.
-Here comes the pity question.
-Thank you for saving us.
-Hi.
-Hi, I'm a premed student
at MCPHS University
and I just happened to see
this talk on my news feed,
very relatable.
So back to the serious
question of, how would you, I
guess, ask a woman to take
off the couple of layers
that society kind
of places on them
and show their real selves?
-Good question.
-That's tough.
That a tough question.
-Or like, what do you
think of Trump's hair too?
-Thank you.
-I mean, I think, I'll just
say in all seriousness,
I think it starts with
not imposing those
on women in the first place.
So it's being more
aware as parents,
as educators, that our young
children don't have to grow up
with one or the other.
They don't have to grow up
with things put on them.
Let them be the kids
they want to be.
And I'm not a hippy parent who's
like, don't give them rules.
I have two kids.
They have some rules.
But I have tried to
let them be the people
that they want to be.
And I know that's
difficult once they
leave the safety of my house.
And I was the mom who walked
into preschool and said,
he does not have to be what
you're telling him to be.
He does not have to play sports.
He does not have to do that.
Let him sing.
That's what he wants to do.
Let him be the kid
he wants to be.
And
Then doing the same
thing for my daughter,
and teaching her that
she should have a voice,
and she should be
a self advocate,
and she should stand up
and say, I don't want that.
You can't do that.
Don't do that to me.
And it's something that
our schools don't often
encourage in kids.
But I argue that
is the way to raise
adults that are going to take
action and be great citizens.
I heard a quote once
that, in school we
tell kids to sit
down and be quiet,
and no one has ever
changed the world
by sitting down and being quiet.
We need to teach
them to stand up
and say what's on their minds,
and say what they believe,
which is a very long
answer to your question.
I don't know the answer
to your question,
but that's how I would start.
-I mean, it's a powerful
question that goes pretty deep,
and we're grappling with it on
our own level at ImprovBoston.
We have about a
year long course,
if you want to
study improvisation,
with a bunch of
different levels.
And we've begun to
actually bake some of that
into the curriculum itself, so
when you walk through the door,
one of the first things
you're going to hear
is, you can be anyone
you want to be here.
This is a safe space.
We're all kids on the
playground playing pretend.
Ultimately, what we
did up here tonight
is to play make
believe for 25 minutes,
and get paid a little
bit for it, right?
It's pretty impressive to
make a career out of that.
The extension, for the many
comedians or aspiring comedians
who come through our
doors, is this idea
that, for at least
three hours, this day,
this week, you can be absolutely
anyone you want to be,
and no one in your
class is going
to tell you can't be that.
And on top of that, you've
got a little taste of it
tonight, where we did
the switch characters,
and then Greg
jumped in and he was
doing the vocal fry at the end.
So we'll do a lot of
that sort of switching
role play in classes
to expand the horizons,
not just of the ensemble,
but of individual players who
can step out of their comfort
zone, and maybe try on a role
that it would never
occur to them to play.
The only stipulation is
that, any role you step into,
you're playing with
integrity, and you're
playing to the top
of your intelligence.
So you're never punching
down, and you're never
scoring a laugh at, isn't
funny that a woman might
be playing the president?
Or isn't it funny
that a guy might be
playing a woman in the scene?
That's never where
the humor comes.
Does that make sense?
-Just, if I may, as a performer.
So I came to ImprovBoston
to do improv late in life.
And prior to that, and still
now, I do stand up comedy.
I think it's important to get
out there and perform and set
an example to people to
be exactly who you are,
no apologies.
This is who I am.
This is the body I have.
This is the person I am.
This is the voice I have.
It's sassy.
It's Kelly.
And I'm going to say
what inspires me.
I'm going to talk about the
things I want to talk about.
I'm going to play my belly in
front of a roomful of people,
because it was appropriate
to what we were doing.
And that I was inspired by
that through the conversation.
Set an example to be
who you are, and it
will set an example for other
people to be accepting of it.
And it will inspire people
to want to do the same.
Thank you so much.
-Trump's hair is
ridiculous, by the way.
-Yeah, how is that?
It's not hair.
-So this isn't
actually my question,
but you were talking
about going to school,
and telling them saying,
let my child be creative.
I just want to let you know that
there is a study that shows,
this is true, they can
tell with 99% accuracy
whom you're going to vote
for, Republican or a Democrat,
based on whether you
feel your child should
be creative or obedient.
So when you're going
to certain states,
I would say don't
tell that story.
But my question is, Aparna
I spent many years in India,
and I don't know if
you go, but I'm just
wondering, when you do--
because the humor there
is, in some ways similar, but
in some ways very different.
I just wondered if
you ever go to India,
and whether you change
the way you do humor
based on that difference
in the audience?
-Well I actually
haven't performed there.
I have family there
still, so I've
visited, but not
in that context,
so unfortunately I
can't speak to that.
But I know that stand
up is now a thing there,
and it's sort of
burgeoning, but it's still
sort of in a initial phase.
So I am very curious to go
and try to do comedy there.
-Where is your family from?
-Hyderabad.
Yep, you're welcome.
-Hi, I'm Sarah.
I'm a local documentary
video producer.
I was thinking
about what I believe
Robin said at the
beginning about,
or actually I remember
it was that said it,
but talking about I think the
transgender rights group that
had asked Stephen Colbert--
-It was Elizabeth.
-Yeah, it was
Elizabeth, wasn't it?
Asked Colbert and Jon Stewart
to openly work with them
on influencing, because
humor has power.
And I just wanted
to kind of hear
your guys' thoughts about
the potential power of humor
as-- somebody asked Neil
Gaiman once, I think,
what he said people always
think the opposite of funny
is serious, but it's
actually not funny.
And I just want to hear
your guy's thoughts about,
especially in this very
politically charged time,
about kind of the role of humor
in challenging existing power
structures, whatever
that might be.
-Yeah well I think
we've seen Jon Stewart
and his show has been
a huge, huge cause,
a huge sort of lightning
rod for so much change
in the last few years.
And most young people
getting their news,
when he was still
running The Daily Show,
from The Daily Show than
any other source, I think,
is pretty powerful.
I think satire and parody
can be hugely powerful,
and nothing changes society
faster than holding a mirror up
to it and saying, can you
see how ridiculous this is?
Do you see it right here?
I have a friend right
now who is touring
the country in a satirical
Trump Sanders debate.
It's called Trump
versus Sanders.
It's touring the
country right now.
He's playing the
Wilbur in a few weeks.
This is a guy I went
to college with.
He is a staunch
Sanders supporter,
and he's playing Trump.
And the reason why he's
doing it is not for laughs,
although it's hilarious.
He's doing it because
he feels like there
is such a short distance
between actual Trump
and something really bad
that's about to happen,
that he's taking the character
to its logical satirical
conclusions.
You can go online and look
at transcripts of the show,
and it is so powerful.
And the audience is laughing,
and they're uncomfortable,
and they're not sure
what to make of it.
But they walk out either
loving the show or hating it,
but they walk out
knowing that they
were delivered a
message, whether they
intended to get one or not.
And I think one of the great
things about comedy is,
we get away with saying a lot of
things that other people can't.
So we're not standing
up and saying,
come hear us preach
about politics,
or come learn this
valuable lesson.
We're saying come laugh with us.
And then we're sneaking
the other stuff in.
Because when you
are laughing, you're
more open to hearing a message.
-Yeah, I worked on this
show called Totally Biased,
that's no longer
in the air, but--
-Just a little show.
Just a little show.
-It's a little mom and pop show.
No, it was on FX, but it was in
the spirit of The Daily Show.
Is like a late night
talk show, but addressing
sort of the intersection of
comedy and social justice.
And the host was like this
liberal, San Francisco
comic named W Kamau Bell.
And I think it was
just really amazing
in that it brought voices to TV
that hadn't had a place there
before.
And just the fact that
someone was delivering
these viewpoints who
had not traditionally
inhabited that space is huge.
So I think it's also, it's not
just bringing social justice
and comedy together, but
it's also like, who are we
giving a platform to do that?
-I do think you have to take
into consideration the context
of the human rights.
The Jon Stewart show is gone,
and so is The Dave Chapelle
Show, so there's a
kind of limited span
in which comedy can be effective
before it gets commodified,
even before time blunts
its edges, right?
So you do have to think about
the longevity of social justice
and humor.
It can happen in a
flash before it actually
goes into feed the very
thing that it's critiquing.
So that's a complicated
thing about social justice
and comedy.
-And I think it's
important, also,
to keep in mind that, for
everyone in this room,
we're talking about
comedy's power
to speak to social justice
or to speak truth to power,
but comedy is just a
vehicle, and that vehicle can
carry pretty much anything.
So when you look at, what is
the mass American consumption
of comedy right now,
it's not actually
The Daily Show, as much
as we'd like it to be,
or Samantha Bee's incredible
new show, Full Frontal,
which if you're not
watching you need to.
It's Two and a Half Men, it's
Jeff Dunham, it's Blue Collar
TV, right?
It's comedy that doesn't seek to
inform or enlighten or elevate
the conversation,
it's comedy that
seeks to score a laugh
at whatever expense.
And it sounds like I'm
talking down to it,
and I don't mean
to, because that
is a very large swath of the
comedy industry right now.
So it has the power to
do a lot more than that.
It also has the power to
punch down and just derive
a laugh at any means necessary.
-I think we're going to take--
what do we have three more
questions, I think?
I'm trying to gauge the line.
Yeah, so let's make
that the next three.
-Thanks, so my name is Tina, and
I'm here at Radcliffe this year
doing a fellowship,
but in my regular life
I'm in profession
where I'm almost always
the only woman in the room.
I'm a neurosurgeon.
And I'm kind of
humorless, but I think
that there are many
situations where
people are
uncomfortable with you
where humor really is helpful.
Can people learn it?
-Yes.
-Oh thank you for the softball.
-You should take a class.
-I just coached-- this is
so funny, because I just,
through ImprovBoston,
had a one-on-one coaching
opportunity last year for
a lovely woman who had gone
through our stand up program.
And she needed one-on-one
coaching and, similar to you--
many degrees, I'm assuming you
have, to be a neurosurgeon.
That seems pretty big.
Very intelligent, super
intelligent woman, and we
basically sat and had sessions
where I was helping her just
tap-- she was hilarious.
And she just didn't quite
know how to flip a switch.
That's the only
difference between someone
who says that they
don't have humor
and this group,
basically, is that we know
how to flip a switch, right?
We can turn it on a
little bit, and we're not
afraid to fine the words.
And yes, you can be
taught, is I'm telling you.
Please see us after.
-And I'll just say that I came
to this work through classes.
I was a teacher and
wanted something
that was going to be fun
for two hours a week.
And I googled it and
found ImprovBoston.
And thought, I'll sign
up and take a class.
That'll be fun.
I'll never perform.
I'm just going to do that
and go home to my kids,
and that'll be great.
And what I found by week
three of my first eight week
class was, oh this is exactly
what I'm supposed to be doing.
And this is going to
changed my life forever.
And it wasn't because
they were specifically
telling me to be funny.
It's because they were telling
me to be myself and find
the truth in myself,
and then the comedy
will come from there.
So I cannot say enough
about improv classes.
They completely changed my life.
We do have the largest
comedy school in New England
so please visit us online
at improvboston.com.
And again we're not
teaching you to be funny.
We're teaching you
to tap into what it
is in you that's already funny.
And I would argue, just
based on the timing
of how you delivered I'm not
funny, brilliantly funny.
This room laughed, right?
-You know what you did.
-You got a huge
laugh from this room.
-You know what you did.
-You're fine.
-She's walking out.
-Hi.
-Hi, my question kind of
falls off of that question.
My name's Dana, and I'm a
perennial student, a bit
of an intellectual magpie.
But right now I'm home
with my 13-month-old baby.
-Yay, congratulations.
-Thank you.
We were at a mom and baby
group, because they're
mom and baby groups, not
parent and baby groups.
-Right.
-And my baby was wearing lots
of blue, blue diaper bag,
blue water bottle.
And one of the other moms with
a baby dressed in frilly pink
says, what your child's name?
And I said, her
name's Evangeline.
And she said, oh so she
has an older brother.
And I said, no we just
like all the colors.
And then turned to the
other woman the other side
and said, I thought,
because of the blue,
I thought it was a boy.
And I find what you're
saying about comedy
holding a mirror, I
always struggle to come up
with a response to that.
How do you find a balance
between being comedic enough
to hold up a mirror
and not being
offensive that it causes someone
to double down and not listen?
-That's a great question.
I don't know that I always do
that successfully, especially
in moments like that.
I was yelled at by a woman in
her 70s at the grocery store
once, because my child, my
baby, was wearing yellow.
And the woman came up and said,
your daughter's beautiful?
And I said, thank you,
this is my son Jackson,
and she yelled at me.
You shouldn't put him in yellow.
What?
That makes no sense.
And my retort to her in that
moment was not very clever.
I think I said something
to the effective of,
you should wear yellow.
Like it wasn't funny at all.
But I don't have,
in those moments,
a lot of impulse control.
-I've realized that I need to
have a repertoire of something
I can say so I'm not
just doubling down and--
-Yeah, I think they're the ones
bringing their own stuff to it.
So hold up a mirror to them.
You said her child was in like
all this ridiculous pink stuff.
Make fun of her
baby is my advice.
I'm sorry.
I shouldn't-- I don' know.
Don't make fun of her baby.
I don't know.
-But that occurred
to me, but I didn't
want to make her get
even more defensive.
-Well I think you're right.
So your original
question, before I
told you to make fun of another
infant, was how do you--
-My baby's got teeth.
What's your baby got?
-Yes, just turn it into a game
of who's got the better baby.
You would win, obviously.
But you very seriously asked,
how do you not provoke people?
How do you use humor and
then not just provoke
the beast and the situation
becomes worse, right?
And I think all
of us, as humans,
have to figure out where that
line is of where it's not worth
it.
My job as an improviser and
a comedian and an entertainer
is ultimately to entertain.
My job as a person is to be true
to myself and have integrity.
And those two have to align.
As an improviser, I'm not going
to purposely get up on stage
and offend anyone.
But if you're making
fun of my baby,
I'm probably going
to say something.
-But I wonder if you didn't
handle that beautifully.
-Yeah.
-Yeah
-Yeah, because I feel
like you did, right?
-Thank you.
-We really like blue.
We like all the colors.
I guarantee you she was standing
at Starbucks later being like,
my baby can wear all the colors.
-Yeah.
-I hope so.
I hope so.
-Like, I think you did exactly
what you were supposed to do.
You were lovely and pleasant,
and you didn't have to like,
well my baby wears blue,
and your baby's wrong.
I think you just
gave the answer.
It was the honest--
-That was my best answer yet.
-Yeah.
I mean I have a stepson.
And as soon as people find out
that I'm a step-mom they go,
oh.
-What is that?
-You know what I mean?
But it's the same
type of thing where
they've got these
buckets that they think
everybody belongs in, right?
Like oh you're just
his stepmother.
You know what I mean?
So I always correct them.
And I've actually, I fell
like I'm getting off topic,
but I want to give
you the example.
He's 10 and a half, and I've
been with him a long time.
And he even knows now what to
say, because I say at home,
and we believe it
and mean it, right?
Whether he was my
stepson or adopted
or whatever the situation
is, my birth child
or whatever, he will
now say to people,
she's my mom by
love, not by blood.
So, I know right?
Literally, I think
you're handling--
why can't we say in a nice
way, exactly what we think?
-That is better advice than
making fun of her baby.
-Although I would
love-- you seem so nice,
I would love to see her
throw down about babies.
Your baby so bald.
I would love to see it.
-Maybe one day.
-Come take a class,
and we'll teach you
how to make fun of
other people's babies.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
I think we have time
for one last question.
Thank you.
-All right, I've
been standing up here
trying to think about
how to make this concise.
-OK.
-My name is Amelia, and I work
for The Theater Offensive,
and a lot of what you
all have been talking
has been stirring and firing
connections in my brain,
and one thing I was thinking
about is this idea of people
change, language
change, stuff changes.
And then we sort of talked about
people creating that change.
And one play that--
I'm a theater artist,
and one play that came
into my mind around this
is Brahman/i by
Aditi Kapil, where
Brahman, who is a trans,
intersex young person
plays with, messes
up, throws in our face
our ideas of binary
gender, and does it sort
of through the stand up lens.
So the whole show
is in stand up.
I watched that show
about a year ago,
and it's against the backdrop
of so many trans women of color
being murdered, and the real
deep danger and risk in truly
being yourself, in
showing your true colors,
and in participating in
that radical self creation.
So I'm curious how, either
as scholars, solo artists,
or as a group, you
can kind of balance
risk and locate yourself
in the skin you're in,
in the body you're
in, in the space
you're in, to be
that agent, making
that change through language?
Kind of a complex question,
but anyone go for it.
-I will put in a plug for
The Theater Offensive.
If you're not familiar
with their work,
go online and look them up.
They do amazing, amazing work.
I can't thank you enough
for the work you guys do.
It's fantastic stuff.
Yeah.
-All right, I'll
take a stab at it.
I think improvisers have it
easier than in some other art
forms, because all you
have to do is show up
and be brave enough to
trust your own voice
in an ensemble of other voices
with people also trusting
their voice.
And then whatever
weird casserole
we make on stage together is
what it is in that moment.
It's certainly,
I think, trickier
for playwrights or
performance artists who
have to get every word right.
-Or professors.
-Or professors, who have
to deliver a lecture that
has to be spot on.
You know you're going
to get challenged
by every student in your class.
With improvisers, once you learn
to trust yourself, and trust
the ensemble, you know
that whatever experiences
you have that lead
you in your life
up to this point are going to
be respected and celebrated
on stage.
And ideally, with the kinds of
crowds we get in improvisation,
the audience is going
to connect with you
and celebrate right
along with you.
We don't get a lot of laughs
with derogatory or scapegoating
or punching down sorts of humor.
The art form in that sense makes
it a little bit more supportive
for us.
What's most interesting
is, when we step outside
of our improv bubble, we do a
lot of anti-bullying workshops
in schools across New England,
social inclusion workshops,
and that's where
we're trying to take
the principles of
improvisation, support, trust,
saying yes to yourself,
saying yes to everyone else,
and then seeing that play out
in a real world seventh grade,
eighth grade, 11th grade,
12th grade scenario where
those principals
are not necessarily
agreed on, not just
by the students,
but dare I say the teachers
and some of the higher level
management as well.
That's where the
rubber meets the road.
And it is not easy, but we
keep fighting the good fight
in trying to change
minds one at a time.
-I think one thing
that I've found
tricky as a stand up and an
improviser, and just a comedian
in general, I mean
if you're a stand up,
you're just bringing
yourself to stage,
and really just you being
authentic to whatever
you believe and who
you identify as is
being honest as a performer.
But I think, sometimes, in
both stand up and improv,
and comedy in general, people--
sometimes in improv, it
would come up where it was
like some person playing
a character of a different
race, or a different sexuality,
and it's like, where is the line
of appropriateness between them
playing it authentically
and them sort
of doing a caricature just based
on their frame of reference,
and not intended to be harmful?
But I think sometimes the
audience will tell you
where that line is.
But there's definitely--
I've seen failure of like,
don't do that accent
of don't walk like.
Comedy involves a lot of
failure, unfortunately,
and making people uncomfortable,
and finding those lines,
societally, where we're at.
-Well, at the highest
level, it really
involved literally being
willing to get burned,
as you probably know if you know
the work of Richard Pryor, who
I've been invoking throughout.
He literally set
himself on fire.
But one of the ways in
which you can read that
is that he talked so
much about the toxic mix
of American racism that he
bitterly burned up through it.
I mean the comedian is
someone-- comedy is a ritual.
People gather to ritualize all
kinds of aggressiveness, right?
And laughter is
the cathartic means
by which we get rid of some
of that aggression, right?
And I think that, in his case
is a really intense example that
speaks to your
question, what does
it take to be able to speak
to your truest self, right?
In his case, it was
really a willingness
to walk this fire line, right?
And he fell, right?
And I mean, in terms of
who we are as performers
of every different kind, you
know Robin is a performer,
improvised, as comedians, as
just the everyday performance
of the self, right, it requires
that you know how far you
can go, want to go, right?
One of the things
that I find most,
it's going to sound like a
really weird non-sequitur,
but one of the
things that I found
most interesting about
teaching at Harvard
when I first got here is that,
with principal fear in students
is their fear to fail, right?
But you're never
going to learn if you
don't know how to
get off the horse
and get back on it, right?
So I think in every
kind of performance
is that playing with
a fire of failure.
Will it get you to learn
and go to a higher place,
or mean that you're just
burned, and you're done, right?
And that playing with that
line is where a lot of humor
comes from, I think.
-Thank you.
What a great evening
with great questions.
Thank you so much.
I'm just going to
thank you, again.
I think that Dean Cohen
has some thanks as well,
and here she comes.
-Well I just want to
ask you all to join me
in thanking everybody
who participated tonight
in giving us a wonderful,
wonderful evening,
and showing us, I
think, that they have
an incredible way with words.
I hope you will join
us tomorrow, when
we go deeper into these topics.
But once again, let's give
them a great round of applause.